-Please give it up for
Kevin Delaney!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kevin.
-Hey, buddy.
-Welcome back to our show.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
What are we doing today?
-We're doing some
wintry-themed things,
so you'll see some
nice decorations
and kind of winter ideas.
So, the first thing --
This is inspired by
the film "Frozen 2."
Have you seen it?
-Yes, I saw it. Loved it.
-No spoilies.
We're calling it "Fire and Ice."
-Okay.
-Okay, so, but first, the fire.
Do you ever use
a fire extinguisher?
Do you have a fire extinguisher?
-Weekly.
-I hope so.
-Yeah.
-A lot of fire extinguishers --
You put out a lot of fires.
Trust me, I know.
So, a lot of fire extinguishers
are filled with
CO2, carbon dioxide, right?
And, so, carbon dioxide puts out
fire very, very well.
So, we have a tank here.
There's a cylinder down there
feeding carbon dioxide
into this fish tank.
I'm going to give you
this lantern.
-Aha.
-So, go ahead.
I'm going to move this lid off,
and you can just lower it down
into the fish tank.
And we'll see
what happens to the fire.
-CO2 is being pumped right now?
-There you go.
And it just goes out.
You can take it out
and then put it down.
-That's fantastic.
-So, most fire goes out
when it's smothered with
carbon dioxide.
Magnesium doesn't do that.
So, we have some magnesium
in this block.
This is dry ice.
-Okay.
-So, dry ice is just
frozen carbon dioxide.
Same stuff, different phase --
that's all.
So, I'm going to
light it on fire.
And then you have your gloves,
and you want to put
that block on top of this block.
We're going to smother it
and we're going to see how it
reacts in a carbon-dioxide
environment, okay?
-And this is just magnesium.
-This is magnesium,
shaved magnesium.
-Shaved magnesium.
-Okay, ready?
-Wait, hold on. No.
-Okay.
-Wait. Do I walk away?
-No, no, no.
-I'm always nervous,
because, yeah, it was --
-So, I'm going to light it.
It's going to take a
couple seconds,
and then you just want to
grab that block
and just fit it on top.
-Okay.
-Okay?
-Yeah.
-So, here we go.
I'm going to light it.
Okay.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, yeah.
You've done this before.
-Ready to go?
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Go ahead and put it on.
Now stand back.
-Whoa!
-And we're going to lower
the lights.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, that magnesium is
just pulling that oxygen
out of the CO2
and creating magnesium oxide.
And that's what the smoke is.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So it burns more energetically.
It's kind of more unique.
-Now, are we allowed to breathe
in magnesium oxide?
-Uh...we're fine.
-Okay, alright.
Thank you, Kevin.
-It's a big room.
There's not too much of it.
-Oh, my gosh. This is awesome.
Alright, I got to do that, yeah.
-Pretty good.
-Yeah. So, kids, ask Santa for
shaved magnesium for Christmas.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-What do we got next, bud?
-So now we have a snowball
kind of bowling ball.
So, what we're going to
talk about now is
the law of
conservation of energy.
So, energy can't be
created or destroyed.
It can only convert from
one form to another.
So that's what we're going to do
with the bowling ball.
-Okay.
-So, go ahead and stand up
against that wall over there.
It's okay. Please, please.
I'm sorry. That was rude.
-No, that's not why
I was concerned.
-So, okay...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...take this bowling ball...
-Okay.
-...and hold it up to your nose.
I'll hang on to it for now.
-Thank you. Yeah.
-So, right now,
what we have here is --
we have potential energy.
When you let go of the ball,
it's going to move that way
and convert to kinetic energy.
It's going to reach its maximum
around the bottom there,
when it --
you know, at the base,
when it's low, I guess.
And then it's going to keep
swinging and convert back into
potential energy
and then swing back.
Now, because we're not going to
give it any force,
it's not going to go
farther back this way
than you released it, okay?
It's not going to go past
your face,
unless you give it extra force.
-Well, then how come you're not
standing here if it's so...
-You can stand -- It's fine.
So, you want to hold it up
to your nose.
Now you want to just
let go, okay?
And you don't give it
any force at all.
-Alright. Just let go
and don't give it any force.
And stand here?
-Yeah.
-And what if I get hit in
the face with a bowling ball?
-You probably won't.
[ Drumroll ]
Okay, ready?
-I think so.
-3, 2, 1...
Just drop it.
-Alright, for a second...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now -- Still stay far away,
because -- Don't --
Don't walk that way.
Don't walk that way
or else -- Yeah.
-It's okay. It's okay.
-Yeah, yeah. Wow!
-And you didn't move.
-I didn't move.
-That's the key.
-I was cool about it.
-Yeah. Very cool.
-I didn't freak out.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was cool.
I didn't freak out.
-Okay.
-What do we have here?
-Venturi effect.
-Venturi.
-Venturi effect. Okay.
So, when airflow is in
a small tube like this,
it creates low pressure.
And if we connect another tube
to that area of low pressure,
anything that's in the tube
is going to get pulled
into that airflow and sucked up.
So, what we have here is
a little mini Venturi tube.
So, all you want to do is give
it a soft and gentle breath
into that end of the tube,
and we'll see what happens.
-This is legal in --
-It's gonna hold -- I think so.
You're almost there.
So, just give it a little blow.
There. Kind of like
a snow globe.
-Oh, yeah.
-Very pretty.
Yeah. So, should we
kick this up a little bit?
-I would, yeah.
-Alright, open the curtain.
[ Drumroll ]
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got some more over here.
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, this is going to be fun.
This is why we pay
you the big bucks, buddy.
Thank you so much.
-Yeah. There we go.
Hello, audience.
Please put on
your safety goggles.
-Aha!
-Thank you very much.
So, what we're going to do is --
we're going to turn
all these on at once
and we're going to observe
the Venturi effect in
all of its glory.
-So we're making a giant
snow globe here in the studio.
-Kind of. Yeah, pretty much.
So, it's going to be very, very
loud, so look at me,
and we're gonna do a
"3, 2, 1..."
And then,
you got your cord there?
-Yep.
-You just want to pull that out?
And I've got these two,
and we should be ready to go.
-Okay, bud.
-Everybody ready to go?
-You guys ready? Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Turn on the blowers.
[ Whooshing ]
3, 2, 1...
Pull.
♪♪
Oh, yeah!
-Thank you very much.
Oh, fantastic!
Kevin Delaney, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]